weeks after the first coronavirus case
was confirmed in Sweden life appears
very much as normal in the cities and
towns people are still allowed to gather
in groups of up to 50 while isolation is
a question of free will the so-called
Swedish model getting support at least
on the streets I think the right
decisions like having a schools open and
so on as long as you wash your hands and
keep a distance it feels like if you're
not in a risk zone then you should be
out it's difficult to say so far so good
primary schools remain open after the
health agency said it doesn't believe
children are strong transmitters of
Kovac 19 testing of which has been
minimal with measures to increase it
only announced on Tuesday beginning with
hospital staff a letter criticizing the
hands-off approach was signed by 2000
people in Sweden's medical community but
plenty supported as well
in most countries politicians take the
decisions and they want to enforce
strict lock down and show strength in
Sweden the leading politicians including
the prime minister told that we should
trust the experts the opposite strategy
to have a complete lockdown is not
sustainable and the worst thing is that
the epidemic you might hit back again
the lesson learned from history is that
we should do everything we can to avoid
the second and the third wave here in
the rinkeby area of Stockholm many
believe they are in the firing line of
the first wave after a number of Somali
elders were among the first to die from
coronavirus Swedish Somali community
leaders are worried about places like
rinkeby who are social and economic
problems make people especially
vulnerable to the virus and its knock-on
effects the Somali Youth Organization
has been spreading awareness of the
pandemic in older people's mother
tongues but fear it may be far from
enough the throne would naturally under
defense people live very close together
many have underlying health problems and
that means many can die
they don't have any where they can
escape to if the virus spreads down
there for those with the means summer
houses on stockholm archipelago are
providing an extreme isolation with some
swedes deciding to stay for months while
the crisis passes the world is fighting
a virus that can infect anybody anywhere
sweden is hoping its own strategy in
this battle proves to be the right one
Paul Reese al Jazeera Stockholm